-In honor of March Madness,
I thought it would be fun
to play Random Object Shootout,
but we're going to need
a little help.
You know them from
their Showtime series,
please welcome Desus & Mero.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-Jimmy! Jimmy!
-Good to see you, man.
We're back.
-We're back, baby.
-We're back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it.
So good to see you.
-The bad news bears.
-Yeah, exactly right.
The bad news bears are back.
-Yes.
-Here's how this is going to
work, alright?
We're going to take turns
trying to shoot random objects
into that hoop, okay?
-All right.
-Now, if you make it,
you get a point.
And the objects that
we're shooting tonight are...
a jumble of sticky hands toys.
[ Light laughter ]
This is a large Easter egg
full of glittery slime.
[ Light laughter ]
-Are you sure?
-Yeah.
This is a picnic basket
full of bouncy balls.
[ Light laughter ]
These are spring daffodils
in a pot, yeah.
And last, the money ball,
worth two points,
is a Julius Randle lego head.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Let's go Knicks.
-Come on, Knicks.
All right, since I'm the host,
I want to go first,
and I'll show you
how it's done, all right.
You guys go back over here.
-Over here?
-Yeah. Here we go.
[ Jazzy music plays ]
♪♪
-It's real sticky.
-Oh!
-Okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the technique --
That's the technique
you recommend?
-Prove me -- prove me wrong.
-All right.
-Jimmy kills it at the "Y"
with the sticky hands.
-All right.
-Want to rub it for good luck?
-Yeah.
Here we go.
-All right.
That's his go.
[ Laughter ]
-You can go underhand.
Whatever you want to do.
-Go underhand.
-You can do anything.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Let's go, let's go, let's go,
let's go, let's go.
-What?
Let's do this!
-How did you know
how to do that?
-How do you know we do?
[ Laughter ]
-How the heck did you
do that, man?
How awesome.
All right, let's go, man.
[ Laughter ]
Pressure's on, man.
-Let's get it, Mero.
Step back!
[ Audience groans ]
-Judges!
[ Bell dinging ]
Judges say, "yes."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good, good, good.
-All right, all right.
It's a tight game, okay.
Good job, Mero.
It's a tight game, tight game.
-Good stuff. Good stuff.
-Yeah, get that sticky off.
I know, it sticks everywhere.
All right. Here we go.
-Come on, Jimmy.
We're rooting for you.
-Thank you, bud.
-I can't go home sticky
to my wife, Jimmy.
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on, come on,
the Cinderella team.
♪♪
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-But, dude -- Wow, all right,
that was just -- all right.
Oh, I see what you're doing.
-Oh, okay.
-There you go.
That's the good luck --
-Got a bigger basket?
-Good luck shimmy there.
Come on. It's the underhand.
Oh, it's like bowling.
-Here we go. Here we go.
-I'm feeling cocky.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
♪♪
-Oh!
-Wow.
-It's just a bit outside.
-Way out, way out. You gotta --
-Come on Mero.
-Hit that backboard.
Let's go.
-Bank shot.
-Bank it. Bank it.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-The egg was
the hard one to do.
-It's not as easy as it looks.
-The egg was the hardest one
to do.
All right. Here we go.
Picnic basket
full of bouncy balls.
-All right.
-All right, I'm going to go --
Should I go underhand
on this one?
-Yeah.
-Go Jimmy, go Jimmy.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Wow.
-Okay. All right.
-That is -- that is going to
take four days to clean up.
-That was incredible.
-How did you miss
every single ball?
-Not one ball went in.
-All right.
-All right, go for it.
♪♪
Cool.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Whose idea was this?
-It's not as easy as it looks.
-It's so tough. All right.
-All right, Mero.
-Here we go.
-Take us home, daddy.
-All right.
♪♪
Here we go.
It's like throwing a baby
in the bath.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Oh!
-I know, it comes back at you.
It attacks you.
-That went in. That was in.
-All right. Here we go.
It's still anyone's game now.
-Got to hit one, Jimmy.
-All right, come on.
-I got this one. The spring --
yeah, I got this one.
♪♪
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Violent.
-A little too angry.
It's violent now.
-I like that.
-Good job. Good effort.
Good job.
-All right, here you go.
-Here you go.
You got this, daddy.
Come on. Let's go.
Let's get it.
-All right.
We're doing this for Eric Adams!
[ Shouts ]
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-I like that same --
that same level of aggression.
-Eric Adams.
-I like the same level
of aggression.
-This is a disaster.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, oh, my God.
-Come on, Mero.
Get big, daddy.
-All right.
Here we go. You got this.
-Loosen me up. Loosen me up.
-You got this, you got this.
-Here we go.
♪♪
-For three!
Oh! It was right there.
-Oh.
-It was right there.
-No.
-She says it --
-Judges say, "No."
-She said, "Yeah."
She said, "Yeah."
-No, no judges say,
"No, no, no."
Here we go. Guys.
It is down --
it is down to the money ball.
[ Laughter ]
The Julius Randle lego head.
And if you score this,
this is two points.
Basically whoever sinks
this wins, basically.
-Going for the money maker.
-Going for the moneyball.
-The game winner.
-Come on, Julius.
Don't let me down, Julius.
Come on.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
Sorry, Julius.
Sorry, Julius. Sorry, Julius.
-Oh. All right.
-All right, it's going to be
one of you guys.
You guys are going
to be the champs.
-Bing bong.
♪♪
-Aw.
-Oh!
♪♪
-For the win. For the win.
-Come on, you got this.
-For the win
or it ends in a tie.
For the win.
Take your time on this.
Come on, bud.
You got this, Mero.
-All right.
Phew. All right.
And here we go.
Go New York.
[ Audience groans ]
-It is a tie!
Desus and Mero are the champs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to them
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.
-We're gonna talk!